now Michael hi I'm and I'm very excited
for this particular segment because I
have two illustrious guests with me to
talk about project cars threes just
announced so I have Pete Moorish
production director and Joe Barron
marking an eSports manager to talk all
about project cars three how you guys do
it yeah okay been a long time since I
got called illustrious by anybody I'm
excited about this because I I used to
be a tuner I was very much into the
amateur racing scene so I've always been
attuned to you Gran Turismo Forza games
project Cars 2 which is fairly recent
all things considered on the racing sim
scene now what can you give the folks
out there who may not be familiar with
project cars so you may have not seen
the breakdown that you guys give can you
break down what's going on with project
cars 3 so I think project cars as a
franchise is pretty well known for its
take on authenticity and it's known for
being pretty pretty beautiful to look at
and it's known for its breadth and depth
of content and we kind of had a
suspicion and this has been backed up
from from talking to people that am Motz
motorsports simulation can be a little
bit kind of po-faced a little bit
elitist a little bit not fun or not mean
your face foam into your night I mean
and so we really wanted to take what we
achieve with project cars to in terms of
authenticity and beauty and so on and
just democratize it a little bit more to
make it more appealing to more people so
we suspect that there's a bunch of
people out there that are ready to take
their first step first toe in the water
towards a more serious racing experience
and we want to kind of be a gateway drug
for those people because as you can
probably imagine week we had Slightly
Mad Studios a mad keen sim races on the
hole and petrol heads and we liked
racing and liked cars and so on and we
kind of want people to love the same
things that we do to see what it is that
makes him racing pretty special I know
Joe you had a lot to say beforehand but
uh can you give a like a little bit of
an elevator pitch for those who maybe
become are coming from project cars 2 2
3
existing fans of speech service are
still being catered for with all the
things that they really liked about
previous two games so we do have this
all new career mode with you can enter
that in your introduction kind of
upgradable cars customizable cars and
things that we haven't done before and
ons but aside from all the new stuff
that kind of for the core fans there's
still the sandbox stuff that they really
liked from the previous two games
meaning if you want to go into to set up
your own custom events all the cars and
tracks and where the settings are
available to you from the beginning and
then on the other side we kind of you
know can't go unnoticed that the sim
racing has really exploded as a genre
and current console generation we
certainly recognize our own part in
supporting that but the genre isn't
always super friendly to new people as
motorsport itself is gathering new fans
all the time you new generation of young
fans and they need a way to learn about
the principles of driving cars fast and
driving cars fast is thrilling and fun
and visceral and kind of scary sometimes
the first few times you do and I think
sim racing sometimes takes the my new
detail and we've done this ourselves in
the past takes the money details so
seriously but they forget that it's
meant to be this high intensity thing
that really gets your blood pumping
so not the kind of entry level lavinia
game we've really made a lot of effort
with improving the controller handling
which we did for project car suit maybe
didn't go as far as we needed to that's
come along a long way for the new game
and then the way we handle assist so
that they're less intrusive than they
were before and better for console
players and kind of encouraging you with
new experience systems they give you
bigger bonuses as you turn this off
altering the AI difficulty up to now
challenge yourself to to get better and
better at the game and then there's also
real-time feedback while you're driving
so and you know your sort of games
telling you oh you've done this corner
really well you've affected this corner
or that overtake with dirty than this
woman's clean through these kinds of
informations coming back to you in the
hood while you're driving as well and
again the experienced guys they know
what mode whether what they know whether
they're driving is good or bad they can
tell us the father they want to but for
everybody else that is
like extra feedback information to help
them find their feet in the Umrah
I want to talk about career mode because
this is always the this is the most
exciting thing about going into a racing
sim is building your profile as a racer
and I know you both of y'all touched on
it a little bit but could you go a
little bit more in depth or point to the
like the biggest things that are going
to attract people to career mode this
time compared to what project cards do
had so I think with them project cost to
it was we we were framing for kind of a
sandbox approach I think so with it with
with a lot of other games you kind of
had to slowly unlock stuff and and we
gave pretty much all of our content out
to players from the get-go and possibly
one of the things we got a little bit
wrong on previous iterations or
misjudged was with leaving people to
find find the fun a little bit too much
so so almost kind of firing and
forgetting and leaving them to find that
they're their own vehicles that they
liked their own tracks that combinations
and that sort of thing and some people
that found that very appealing other
people wanted a little bit more support
and so that's what we're doing with with
the career mode this time around so the
the sandbox side of things if you just
want to jump in and race a certain car a
certain track in certain weather
conditions that's all there and it's
underpinned by the divide by an
iteration by an enhanced version of the
physics and handling that that we've had
previously but yeah the career mode is
is it's much more of a gateway to it is
more of a kind of Greatest Hits it's I
hate the word curated but I can't think
of a better one at this point of the
sentence I'm going to go with it anyway
so it's much more of a cricket or a 2
curated experience where where we're
taking people is it's less championship
based less race weekend based less
calendar based and it's more about
skipping from from from track to track
to track for shorter kind of more
adrenaline hit sort of races so as it's
not it's not necessarily all about doing
a championship and and finishing in the
points every time to earn the rights to
go to the next races where you do the
same in the same we've got a wider
spread of objectives to meet more choice
points better support for people if then
when they get stuck better support for
nudging people towards dialing back the
difficulty sorry darling darling back
the difficulty and the assists and
things Iraq and so on yeah it's it's
we're hoping that that it should be all
things to all people in terms of
experiencing the breadth and depth of
content and in terms of kind of a
friendlier more democratic take on
fairly on a more serious simulator style
game Jo I know you we were talking about
this a little bit as well and P touched
on it is the changes to assists now not
everyone is a professional driver I
think I might be but again though the
goal is that in a few months Michael get
more people on though and like make this
less of an intimidating thing but you've
also I think the thing that stood out to
me is how you explained how race lines
are changing and could you go more in
depth of how you're doing that yeah so
they're kind of the breadth of this this
is what for the most part is what you
would expect from a sin game in terms of
things like traction control stability
control antilock brakes those kinds of
things stuff you used to see in the
menus of all racing games but one of the
things that we really wanted to get away
from in terms of helping people to
become better drivers was this idea of
the kind of the main assist that
everybody relies on when they start
playing serious racing games which has
been a key partner genre for the last 10
years which is the racing line assist so
showing you the best route through the
corners and breaking points and things
like that and everyone including
ourselves over the last to say last 10
years has been doing that with a painted
line basically on the opposite but
changes color when you need to brake or
lift off the throttle or get get back on
the throttle and things like that and it
basically it becomes a crutch for people
they start driving games basically like
they were in games they're waiting for
the color to change or the line to
change and reacting to it rather than
building any sort of useful muscle
memory for the car will attract or for
driving in general so what we've done
instead is throwing that way and
replaced it with a braking marker or
track marker system so
the game is dynamically showing you
suggested breaking points suggested
turning points the suggestion for the
apex of the corner which in laymen terms
is the kind of center point exactly you
want to hit as you're moving through the
corner with the front wheels and then
I'd point on the exit of the corner that
you should be aiming for as you're
driving away and putting the throttle
back on and that are just dynamically
depending on the car or driving and the
cars are upgradeable now so it takes
upgrades into account as well and the
idea is with that you're sort of without
realizing it you're learning about where
to brake on each circuit where it's a
break in different classes of car where
to turn in it's helping you to learn
that you can turn in later or earlier in
this class of car because now you've got
more downforce maybe you're gonna know
from your car something like that and
and then it's the less of a shock to the
system then when you turn that stuff off
what we see over the years with the
traditional racing line assist when
people first turn it off it's almost
like starting again because they
suddenly realize I've been completely
reliant on this thing whereas now this
is building a muscle memory up and
making you a better driver rather than
sort of almost like teaching it's a
quick attire or something yeah that's
that's a fairly good way to put it you
know I think that you know you relying
on racing lines can definitely make a
racing game feel monotonous if you don't
use it as a as a jumping off point but
speaking of like progress and getting
better I think that you know we see a
lot of games now are trying to build
something around like making progress
and kind of unifying how much progress
you're making in the game whether it's
like through experience points levels
unlocking stuff can you go into depth
about how project cars is tackling that
and giving players a better progression
system yeah basically we have this kind
of this kind of overarching meta game
layer so whatever you're doing in the
game you have any experience points that
contribute to your driver level and in
the single-player modes and in the
multiplayer modes you're building a
personal Garret of upgraded and
customizable cars we for the first time
in franchise and your driver level is
basically gating which cars you can
at any one time I used the word buy as a
relative we're talking in-game credits
there are no micro transactions which is
something we really wanted to avoid and
so yeah the idea is particularly in the
single-player career if you happen to
latch onto a car really early and you've
got a personal favorite really early on
you can instead of spending your credits
on a new car next time you move up a
class you can upgrade the car you
already in and all the cars have a
performance index rating which is
essentially a number that dictates
weight class they're in and once you
once it passes a certain level the car
moves up to the next class and so yeah
you can carry a car through the whole
career mode if you want to within reason
some of the Karo cars actually have full
race upgrade kits attained change them
from you can upgrade them and they're
still a road car but there comes a point
where now they need to be full-fledged
race car downforce and roll cages and
all that sort of things that you can go
as far as that with some of the road
cars as well which is cool the only
restriction we have really is that we
don't let you sort of upgrade a road car
to the point where you're racing against
you know you're putting on track against
an IndyCar or some other open wheel or
something like that you know we have a
we do take pride as everybody knows in
the authenticity of the game and we're
maintaining that in the sense that you
know bespoke cars and championship still
remain is in that way but yeah the rest
of the game as far as I'm grading grown
cars taking them into sort of the
particularly the GT classes that sort of
thoroughbred race cars based on road
cars you can certainly take them up
through that route which is really cool
and yet then customisable liveries
patterns paint materials paint colors
sponsor stickers all that kind of stuff
as well which then all this stuffing
that you're doing to the cars and your
garage carries into multiplayer as well
so you're creating a sort of driver
persona and a personalized experience
that carries between all the modes
compared to a project cars - I I was
playing a little bit earlier this week
in preparation as I had in the past I
played a lot of project cards - what are
you are there significant changes in the
roster of cars this time around since
you can start upgrading cars in project
Carson
sure I mean it's it's a matter of bigger
better more when it comes to vehicles
and and tracks so we've got I think at
least 40 more vehicles including some
manufacturers that they haven't been in
the franchise before which is which is
pretty exciting
and we've got 13 new track locations
each with a number of different track
barians and so we're yeah we've whereas
someone got the number of on tracks now
and so there's a few that you listed in
the video we prepared and there
Interlagos which is the Brazilian Grand
Prix track and a couple of fictional
tracks one based in Tuscany on base in
Shanghai so they're there they're kind
of two different the fictional ones are
speaking to to two different and those
streams or two different takes on an
idealized fictional track Shanghai as a
city track which has a very very
different persona at night than it does
during the day so at night it's all neon
and reflections and it's it's it's quite
a thing to see the Tuscany track is much
more about being in the countryside that
kind of road trip mentality but treating
the road trip as a race track instead
but they're both they're both excellent
tracks created and prepped by people
that understand town to Bob together a
decent range restaurant we've revisited
all the tracks from the project last
year as well with a very nerdy
fine-tooth comb
it's obviously three years since project
cars 2 came out so lots of the real
world circuits that we already had have
undergone safety changes or like the
types of curbs have changed and all
sorts of little things so we've been
back into the nice review of those as
well so then there's Acuras that can be
I think that one of the one of the
criticisms I saw a lot of project cars
too was the AI and how AI driver is
behaved can you speak to the changes
that you're making for project karts 3
in terms of how AI behavior is handled
would you certainly look tight a lot
from point of view of making them more
consistent and increasing the
believability and we're not we're not
going so far as
we're not rubber banding things to
change the experience or anything like
that were very much about the
authenticity but we think now that for
sure people are going to have a better
experience in terms of predictability in
a positive sense you're going to start
to be able to do the sorts of things you
would expect to do against a real driver
as far as understanding when they're
going to turn in when they're going to
leave you space for an overtake those
kinds of things I'm just making it more
consistent across across the it's a huge
variety of cars in the games world which
will help people out a lot
yeah one area where people criticize
probably cast too it was Wizards Joe
mentioned the inconsistency of AI and
it's quite a difficult thing to get
right so you can you can have it
perfectly balanced first seven out of
ten tracks but then one or two of those
other tracks can be the AI can be kind
of unbeatable or it can be super easy
Balian inconvenience and you need to be
able to we need that can consistency
across the board and yeah we've given
ourselves the bandwidth to to sort of
self out this time you also mentioned
that there's skill based matchmaking in
multiplayer so if you don't want to play
against AI there's a of course a
multiplayer component but can you speak
to some of the changes especially skill
based matchmaking and how that works in
project karts 3 sure it's a big change
for us because you know in the second
game we had this driver license system
that was essentially when you were
playing online rating your skill level
your sort of safety you drove and how
fairly you drove as well and online
races but we didn't do enough with it in
in some way so that information was
there and you could set up custom
lobbies with restrictions on people's
license level of who can you can enter
those lobbies or not but this time we
really needed to go one step further
with that we have done so all the
multiplayer modes have skill based
matchmaking be that you know pressing
one button to jump into quick race or
doing something more serious we've also
got scheduled events so that essentially
means sort of various times of the day
every single day and all the time zones
where the game will be available you'll
be able to look at a list of events
which are sort of set by us as a
development team and they'll have
certain cars tracks number of laps
weather conditions things like that
you choose one from the menu and then
you can register for the race you can
jump into a qualifying session so your
qualifying time and when the time comes
for the chedrools event to start
everyone who's registered for the race
gets mashed together and then splits
into groups based on the driver license
level that we're talking about and gets
into the action that way which is really
cool and then we've still got custom
bobby's and things for people who want
to run League races or just race private
races with their friends stuff like that
and then we also have rivals mode which
is a kind of asynchronous daily weekly
and monthly challenges mode but we've
really kind of gone one step further
with this is to think about how people
react to sort of leaderboard based modes
and often in racing games the guys at
the very top of the leaderboards will
incinerating the tournament gets thrown
around a lot is aliens these kind of
unbeatable seeming guys that people
don't necessarily understand what it is
that they're doing and watching
amazement that it's always hard to say
how do I reach that level and we've seen
that ourselves as developers with people
playing our games you know development
we all sit around thinking this is going
brilliantly look how quick I am making
yourself against the development team
and then you see the community if it
changes your mind so what we really
wanted to do is to give people a level
to weigh in that so the leaderboards in
the daily weekly monthly challenges are
split into divisions so what that means
is and you're not just seeing the top
hundred guys in the world you might be
saying the top ten top thirty top 50
guys in your division and you can strive
to be at the top of that division even
if you're not necessarily going to be
one of the very top guys in the world
every single event and then at the end
of each month the division cycles some
people get promoted to the next tier up
thing some people get demoted to the
next tier down and so that's going to be
a really cool way for people to come
back every day get new challenges that
were setting for them and then really
have a better way of not just gauging
themselves against the community at
large but against their nearest rivals
and then we also have dynamic ghosts in
there as well so not only do you have
the leaderboard as a measure for how
you're doing that if you are in say a
time trial rivals event where lap time
is the key thing that matters the game
will dynamically load the next ghosts at
the end of every lap so
you're always being given the ghost for
the next few people ahead of you on the
leaderboard and you've got that kind of
carrot on a stick to keep going and keep
challenging yourself so it's it's all
wrapped up in making simracing more
accessible and helping people to
understand what will make them a better
sin racer and then giving them kind of
targets to aim for as well Joe I know it
says yet your your eSports manager is
there anything you can share in terms of
a push for erasing with project karts 3
so yeah we've been doing official
competitions World Championships in the
gang since 2015 when the first one came
out and over those last five years which
feels like a long time isn't I guess
it's a yeah we've been kind of getting
more and more sophisticated every year
and bigger and bigger partners just last
week we announced Logitech G challenge
which is in its third year and is still
carrying on for the time being in
project cars - and that's a really great
example of the sorts of things we do
which is focused on kind of grassroots
sim racing and finding the next wave of
talents gonna come up and be the Nexus
of pro eSports Americas which is a group
of guys that's getting bigger and bigger
all the time but it's certainly
something we're proud of is looking for
the next wave of talent coming through
and the prize for that competition
actually is - hoping the world comes
down and allows us to do the prize and
in the way we want to but the prize is
its global competition that the prizes
and all expenses paid trip to London to
come and have an experience driving at
McLaren racecar and get some driver
training from land owner s1 Clarins for
long drivers as well both sim driver
training and real world which is pretty
cool and then yeah next year we'll all
probably starting towards the end of
this year and coming back next year in
full will have to our next World
Championship in which you'll switch
obviously to project a story and watch
them and ask me about that in the ng
course in terms of who will partner with
those sponsors and stuff like that
should be cool you know if we talked
about a lot of different things and it
seems like project karts 3 is doing a
lot to to upgrade itself from - and also
differentiate itself from others and
racers out there is there anything that
you uh that we haven't covered that you
want to point out with project cars -
they'll get either returning players or
newcomers
really excited about this so one of the
things that I quite like that we haven't
really touched on this is we've talked a
lot about the authenticity and and and
the the intensity and is reality and so
on we're applying a bunch of kind of
interesting and graphical effects so
we've upgraded the graphics engine in
this in this version of the game and
we've we've done that too almost for a
stylistic point of view so so when
you're when you're racing very very
quickly if you get if you're if you
can't go about that race driver tunnel
vision where you're just focused on that
on the next corner the we kind of
simulate the intensity so then we
fictionalize a little bit in terms of
maybe adding some motion blur around the
edges of the screen and kind of really
trying to simulate the the or not to the
intensity that the real-life the racing
driver would would experience and then
snap them out of that when they crash or
if they if they misjudge something then
it's more of a shock to the system
so it's certainly somewhere where we've
amplified the effect by fictionalizing a
little bit the the effect of speed and
the effect of the sudden absent in from
my side I think I also want to say thank
you to the fans you know they're the
reason that were able to make a third
game in the first place and for a studio
like ours to be in a position to do that
is really cool and then and if the core
fans on top of all this other stuff
about democratizing simracing and
bringing it to more people we've got
lots of stuff that were yet to enhance
for the fan base as well so she
definitely keep an eye out for some of
the some surprises as far as new brands
of cars coming new some more new
circuits that we've still got to reveal
and there's going to be lots of stuff on
people's wish lists that's gonna start
popping up over the next few months so
definitely look forward to that Pete Joe
thank you so much for joining me looking
forward to this because I haven't drove
in a while since I've been living out
here in San Francisco
but I'm looking forward to doing it
again when project cars three rolls
around so thank you so much for joining
us
you
[Music]